the mortal kombat series is known for
infamously violent fatalities and a deep
roster of badass fighters from realms
across the multiverse
translating these fighting games into
movies is no easy task
here are the five best and five worst
scenes in 2021's mortal kombat
mortal kombat puts its best foot forward
in an opening that takes place
centuries before the rest of the movie
sub-zero comes to hanzo asashi's home to
assassinate him
and his family after seeing his son and
wife killed
and frozen by the cryomancer hanzo goes
on a rampage tearing through a legion of
assassins with his iconic
kunai rope this leads to an epic
showdown between the two the actors
playing the iconic mortal kombat duo joe
taslim and hiroki sonata are veterans of
martial arts and samurai cinema
the bouts between them are by far the
highlight of the 2021 mortal kombat
adaptation
and the first one gets the movie off to
a rousing start
sub-zero walks away the victor leaving
hanzo dead
as the screen fades to black and the
title card fades in
it's time for mortal kombat a strength
of the latest mortal kombat
is the direction and choreography of its
hand-to-hand combat
unfortunately this means the scenes
where the actors have to fight against a
cgi opponent
stick out like a sore thumb amid the
visually superior physical action
the worst of these is a warehouse fight
where coal sonia blade and kano face off
against an invisible
human-sized reptile seeing the actors
fight against
air definitely breaks the believability
of the scene when their adversary
is invisible the effects aren't
convincing enough to give you a solid
sense of its scope or location
when we do get a glimpse it still
doesn't seem like much more than a
generic beast
once kano punctures the lizard with a
flare he becomes a whole lot easier to
see
and well you know what's coming next
still even when the cast
isn't punching at nothing the scene
doesn't manage to excite
the special effects on the lizard don't
look especially stylish or cool
the end result is the most forgettable
fight of the entire movie
eagle-eyed mortal kombat fans
undoubtedly noticed from the trailers
that early on in the movie jax is
lacking his defining characteristic
his two cyborg arms it doesn't take long
for the movie to show the traumatic
incident that caused
jax's epic transformation the early
scenes where jack says both his human
arms can be interpreted as a nod to
mortal kombat 2
the game where the character made his
debut in the 2021 mortal kombat
sub-zero is the one responsible for
jax's dismemberment
after hunting down jax cole and his
family
sub-zero lures jax into battle the two
have an intense combat session that
leads to a pretty gnarly time for jax
when sub-zero freezes his arms
until they explode into a bloody mess of
ice and viscera
in the middle of the film liu kang finds
coal sonia and jax in the desert and the
movie decides the real plot should start
now the legendary protector takes the
crew to raiden's temple where the earth
realm protectors have the entire
backstory of mortal kombat
and outworld explained to them liu kang
tells the protectors about the
tournament and that's kind of his role
for the entire movie
it is a major letdown to have the main
hero of a majority of the mortal kombat
series
relegated to doling out to exposition
and training the characters that
actually get to fight
in less than 10 minutes of its total run
time mortal kombat introduces
three major characters and sets up the
conflict for the rest of the adventure
it's a rushed scene
full of exposition that reiterates
information that
most mortal kombat fans already know
despite being squeezed between two
action sequences
this scene still manages to kill the
momentum in the middle of the movie cole
unlocks his true potential when the
four-armed goro is about to kill his
family
with wife allison and daughter emily in
harm's way
cole taps into his arcana his body
turning into an
energy absorbing armor not unlike the
black panther costume
sure the cgi heavy fights in mortal
kombat aren't the best but
the final moments of this sequence more
than make up for that
when tapping into his power cole
materializes his weapons
and proceeds to absolutely go to town on
goro
only one of cole's weapons is bladed but
it definitely feels like an homage to
tanya's in mortal kombat deception
and armageddon kano is the ultimate
loudmouth and this scene is him at his
sweariest
angriest and most overtly racist
kano exudes machismo and spews some
serious
anti-asian sentiments as kung lao and
luke hang agamon to try and see his
true power it's only then that we see
kano's laser eye in action for the first
time in the movie
the scene goes way overboard on how
offensive kano acts to the point where
it begins to give away the twist that
happens later on
there's no way you were supposed to root
for kano after this if it wasn't
obvious kano was destined to betray the
protectors to shang tsung
this scene makes it painfully clear that
he is
not a good guy fighting games are known
for creating some of the biggest
character rivalries in gaming and
sony and kano go way back as storied
rivals
additionally fans of the original 1995
movie
are sure to be reminded of the pair's
classic face-off
the new movie leans hard into kano being
a foul-mouthed
scumbag he's always been known for being
cunning and
untrustworthy the latest portrayal of
kano is no different as he betrays sonja
and
the heroes of earth realm by removing
the shield of protection around raiden's
temple portraying sonia's trust
most of all this relationship makes the
final showdown between the two
supremely satisfying when sonia finally
unleashes her
garden gnome based fatality on kano she
earns her dragon mark and finally
becomes the protector of earth realm she
was destined to be
not long after the protectors make it to
raiden's temple sonia discovers jax is
alive and being cybernetically enhanced
as he recovers jack struggles with
getting accustomed to his new body
thankfully sonia is there to give a
motivational speech that works
wonders for jax but leaves the audience
a bit cold
the attempt to develop this crucial
mortal combat relationship
is a bit too little too late molestonian
jacks are indeed partners and have a
close friendship in the games and
comics lore the connection doesn't come
across as well in the newest movie
sonia's words of motivation clue into
the duo's military background
together but the monologue doesn't land
on an emotional level and
false flats as the movie barrels forward
in
the biggest twist of the whole movie
cole's ancestor warps back from the
depths of the nether realm to finally
defeat sub-zero
once and for all right before sub-zero
is about to deal a death blow to coal
hanzo's kunai launches its way into his
arm before the ancient hero lets loose
his
iconic battle cry it wouldn't be a
mortal combat movie without
at least one get over here now would it
it is once again worth mentioning how
fantastic the action and choreography
are in the scenes featuring these two
martial arts film stars
the climactic action sequence fully
delivers on being one of the best in the
movie
featuring weapons fists and magic powers
in equal measure hanzo fully makes the
transition to scorpion
and finally finishes sub-zero with the
fire breath fatality mortal kombat fans
remember from way back in the day at the
arcades
it is hard to top the climactic battle
between scorpion and sub-zero but mortal
kombat wraps up so quickly and abruptly
it's hard not to feel like you fell
asleep or missed something of the final
scenes the one that feels
most rushed is the confrontation between
the leaders of each realm
thunder god lord raiden versus the evil
shang it ends up being less of a
confrontation
and more of a short conversation after
it becomes clear that raiden and the
forces of earthrealm have defeated their
outworld foes
changsung teleports into the scene to
tell the heroes the fight is not over
yet
he swears he will get his revenge and
then it looks like raiden is preparing
to battle in one last epic fight
but that is not what happens instead
raiden uses a lightning blast to send
shangsung back to outworld
buying time to gather more allies for
the sequel check out one of our newest
videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite action movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one